[Musique]
bonjour madame bonjour Vous habitez le
quartier oui vous connaissez la rue
Berte morizo à vra dire non bonjour
madame bonjour Alors vous la connaissez
bien cette rue Berte morizo oui ça fait
au moins plus de 10 ans que je fais ma
tournée colis sur la chancellerie et oui
je la connais bien oui tout à fait et
berth morizo vous la connaissez et ben
non pas du tout et vous connaissez berth
morizo ben je sais que c'est une peintre
j'ai regardé ces tableaux mais après bon
j'en connais pas plus et desreux porte
des noms de femmes vous en pensez quoi
c'est magnifique pourquoi parce que on
est des femmes il faut qu'on soit là
quoi c'est dommage surtout à notre
époque je crois que en plus on a
beaucoup de femmes maintenant qui se
font je sais pas ouais des médecins des
ministres tout ça donc pourquoi pas
porter les mettre dans des LRU quoi
voilà tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
simplement bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue rue berth morizo la ville de
bourge a la chance de voir naître en 184
cette grande figure de
l'impressionnisme son père préfet du
Cher et sa mère arrière petite nièce du
peintre Fragonard encourage sa vocation
d'artiste femme et peintre ces tableaux
sont des hommages aux femmes dans un
style et une sensibilité très
personnelle elle est l'une des seules
femmes du mouvement d'avant-garde
baptisé
l'impressionnisme avec Mony de gar
Renoir Pissaro cicelet berth participe
en 1800 73 à la création de la société
anonyme coopérative des artistes
peintres sculpteurs et graveurs premier
jalon du courant
impressionniste de 1875 jusqu'à sa mort
berth morizo exécute des centaines de
toiles exposé aujourd'hui dans les plus
grands musées du monde elle s'éteint en
1895 à l'âge de 54 ans elle laisse une
œuvre infiniment
[Musique]
impressionnante
alors nous allons maintenant à la
rencontre de Mélanie Elzingre Alya
zomeeka artiste peintre et qui est
justement en train de réaliser une
œuvre bonjour Mélanie bonjour alors
qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train de
faire et bien je suis en train de
peindre le sol je considère un peu du
coup le bitum aujourd'hui comme une page
d'uncarnet de croquy un peu plus dans
une direction d'aquarelle aujourd'hui
par que je peint avec du blanc de Medon
et c'est une peinture qui sera éphémère
et qui partira à la prochaine pluie et
je crois que vous invitez même les gens
à marcher dans vos uvres oui l'idée
c'est d'échanger avec les gens ou les
passants à venir traverser l'œuvre et
repartir ensuite en rue pour traîner un
petit peu une trace de de cette œuvre
derrière soi et quel lien vous feriez
entre le travail que vous connaissez de
berth morizo et le vôre moi j'ai été
aussi étudiante en art plastique à
l'université alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
peut-être à un moment donné le côté un
peu étude classique qui pourrait être
une base commune même si honnêtement ce
que on étudie à l'université n'est plus
forcément le dessin académi comme Bert
morizo et ses pères ont dû aussi voilà
cétait une étape de passer par le dessin
l'académisme avant d'avoir même le droit
de toucher à la couleur je pense que
Bert morizo on a ce point commun
d'appartenir à un collectif de peintrre
et on va dire philosophe aussi et d'être
dans son époque ancré avec les pratiques
du moment et quel regard vous posez en
tant que femme sur la place des femmes
dans votre secteur d'activité euh
aujourd'hui la pratique c'est
complètement démocratisée ça c'est
ouvert aussi je pense qu'on est dans une
époque où même la question des genres a
complètement éclater également et et la
place de la femme je pense plus que ce
soit quelque chose à revendiquer sur
l'espace public c'est quelque chose qui
est de fait merci beaucoup Mélanie bon
ben vive la poésie dans l'espace public
les femmes et puis les coups de cœur et
puis surtout n'oubliez pas des fleurs
des cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peur